[оплески]
[музика]
що
опіум i hold you can more руку до
обласканий проекту а у
бен warlock
перемозі як він був від нас далекий
як
[музика]
він обгорів еблі
він
[музика]
амандин танкістів дата його я повз
саліховна за танкістами
повітряний парад
очолює групу із чотирьох літаків
складі льотчиків підготовчої групи
крапелька провідний групи старший льотчик
випробувач
селякова крістина андріївна по червоній
площі проходять парадний розрахунок
і раз потрібно
так
майор
все na'vi колоди
низької бронетехніки
фляжка
пам'ятайте
пам'ятайте у flash у 100 г фронтових
ніж більше консерву як завжди на
війні
це zuber на таро це був відкритий
губернатору весь час
сьогодні багато
що мого занепалому
перемога буде за нами хлопці основна
завдання виконано виконано на п'ять с
плюсом
сумарно у нас 3 300
[музика]
ось блясти мужик не розбила скло
щойно на
1 ceramica флот розбив
яку війну ти що дивитеся зробив
приблизно терасі хід розбив
яку війну
України
[музика]
за темою готувалася
ти слухай поїдемо пивка поп'ємо геть у мене
на задньому сидінні доручив сидіння
російських мене покликаю басків люблю
мікрофон і ззаду фіз мастила життя в мене
богемна казка її проміняти ні на що
не згоден як тільки приходить зверху
указ мені я відразу в строю погляд але і
небезпечний кидаюся пропаганда як червона
ікрою ну нею ми ними [ __ ] бойовий
таких як я в Росії повно на сцені
театру і в кадрі кіно співаючих танцюючих
блогерів ботів ми арміям і медійна роду
там ці кріп та нацистське дно співають за
життя дітей вдома мамам градів
словесних удару щоб захистити своїх
гонорар
договору матроської про спецоперацію
росії
афоном нам допомагати їм і наша музика
хто знаючи слова піци ви то я вова і
вежах запилювати овалу і ваших були
хтось за роботи або школи кріп танк і
на ньому треба було за там чого деза
приховувати пиття вивчені ніч яка місячна
зоряна ясно немає
вимовити москаль них теж і проти ти
б і дар ти ебаний до піку то куди
я незвичайним ящик це все неправильно
мережах ну не нормально а російського арте
мені здається вона просто робить свою
роботу підтримуєте поліцію та
розгвардію робота я підтримую а ви що
ці біля затримати не можуть
звичайно якщо ні їсти я порушуватиму
заднього ряди люди стоять вас можуть
затримати ні йому впевнено звичайно
тут у мене ніхто не затриманий і
провокує спеціально ось вони підходять
ось я дивився передачу та ось підходить
звичайний житель відзначив підходить взяв
вдарив розгул співробітника росгвардію по
особі на чолі його вдарю але вважаєте це
нормально тому що роблять подивіться
на нього
є їх почати і проведемо все, що вони
будуть провокуватися правильно вони тіло
дія які за законом укази
[оплески]
так скоро тихо гайки смердять а ціни
чи знаєш танка і
за раз його танкіст по ви
[сміх]
так що армія
чотирма хід вас про сир моцарелла
техніка мені у всьому капоніри тут
будь ласка блювати відразу вище за всіх якоюсь
посрал [ __ ] викину 3 і сміття [ __ ] і
і йшов і йшов сміттям клапана вірити
собі поїхав поїхав по їх обидві руки по
біжу біжу тут
намальовані хрест
допомогли вся
все посрав і
пішов стій
будь ласка тут або була їдальня
тут води де ви візьмете поїв посрал на
вірі coupe кота всю і в техніку
козли
[оплески]
[музика]
асе та
c залужний muted big
fish
fashion
[музика]
wish